Đây là giạm đầu tiện thiếu nát mà tạm lươi hình trong học sinh gặp nè hảm gú
Để thay thành chỉ cho bị cơ cả đạo mà máy trong mối rơi
Soại này cũng ba sẽ không có cái điều thành
Thở là không biết anh là nè đau đâu
Bụi thì không biết anh là
Đúng là
Thếm là những hả bạn tòa nét cho mấy hết cái này thì mặt lại quên nhạc
Ló sức có hai cách
Đúng không?
Cái người là đi em
Cái người là bạn làm cái chí đau
Các bạn tình kẹo sống nó là cái bỏ xét của ông
Cái xú hai là
Ló tà rảo
Cô tà rảo, có không chỉ là tà rảo
Cái này là xin này là xin li của đây
Rồi nào mình trọng rồi
Thôi nào mình ăn rồi
Thôi nào mà nào
Thôi nào mà ăn xe luôn nhé
Thôi nào mình xe thì nó không binh sâu
Bốn là 2 bếc thì nó không binh sâu
Thôi sao?
Thôi rồi này này
Thôi nào mà xe nào
Cái này mình cần là xin 3 cái năm rồi
Xe mà mình ăn
Thôi thì mình sẽ vào bây nguang
Thôi nào mình ăn thôi là 3 bếc
Chu viên sâu hả mình bố bếc
Thôi nào mình là bố bếc cho bếm sâu nhé
Thôi sao mà như quái nhé
Thôi thôi mà mình ăn ngon này
Thôi rồi mà
Thôi nào mà ăn trong ngu lo
Thôi trong ngu lo
Thôi nào mình ăn xin lại nó ngon
Thôi nào mình hả?
Chuy nó một trần tham rồi
Hả?
Thôi nào mà mình ăn xin lại
Thôi mà cậm cậm đựa
Thôi thôi cậm đựa
Chuy ra thì
Dồi rồi thì mình ăn Rồi
Gó ở đây chuy hình rời
Thôi thì ăn cho không đây
Thôi nào mình ăn xin lại
Thôi mà vô không còn b took bếc
Thôi này thì nó ăn cậm đựa
Thôi này nó ăn 1 bếc
Chuy ra, ngon 2 bếc
Hãy xong đi, bắt đi em.
Tổn đi của bằng khá lúc bằng mất.
Bây giờ bây biến sảo, nha.
Chứ mà nhớ đặt, môi mục phần hai cứu.
Chứ mà phòng hả?
Chứ mà phòng.
Đúng đặt, hả?
Chồng nha, phòng đi ở phòng biến.
Mẹ chờ, quá đẹp luôn.
Quá để xong đi.
Rồi, xong mô mì ra.
Chứ bây giờ, mực biểu của cũng đi, tình xong ra đâu.
Nhưng mà có một cái nét, cái trụ này thì thích nghĩa có là thích khó rất đúng không?
trong trường này có con người trong những thời gian tâm hiểu trong các bạn là cái trình nào ở trường này
có đúng người nhật
em có đi theo trong đúng người này có thể có thể có thể bị trình nào
là thời gian tâm hiểu trong một cái trình nào
thì sẽ được đi
có rất nhiều cách cái trình này
chung ra
thì bây giờ bạn có thể hiểu của mình quên lý cơ bản trong vòng hần giang
trởi vì trởi vì tâm hiểu của mình quên lý cơ bản
quên quỷ, muốn lý này là trình hỏi về chiều quay của hần phần ra
tây lấy dụng rồi
tất cả cái trường
Chúng ta có thể chứ bà.
Trong lưu ngốc qua là một trong 2 m Độ.
Đúng trò, thì m dì thằng ai nè.
Đây là thử dụng tên bây bỏ một sau dây.
Còn mà, thì thơ dụng.
Đây bỏ không có nà, bây.
Còn phải nà, bây.
Chứ mới quen gửa lại nè.
Bỏ một trong 2 m Độ.
Đúng không? Đó là chơi thì bây bỏ không.
Chúng không? Đó là chơi thì bây bỏ bà.
Thôi là bà đoang nhạc.
Thôi là bỏ một trong 2 m Độ.
Bây bỏ một trong 2 m Độ.
Chúng không? Đúng không? Đúng không?
Bà đoang thì đoang không bị phong đồ, bây bỏ.
Còn biến sống.
Đúng không? Nó là bà đoang.